i'm assuming i mean obviously
803 legend is out uh carolina narco is
out
um i mean i'm assuming you already got
a whole another project yeah i'm
thinking ready to go
um i got another project ready but i'm
i'm thinking about dropping their own
deluxe
before the end of the year out for uh
for eight or three legs
chopper deluxe probably add like three
new songs and something with some
features
no i just like i got some hard [ __ ] with
y'all school to like
hey scooters doesn't get the props he
deserves yeah
we came up we came up like uh listening
in the school like school it was crazy
yeah yeah yeah you know he i feel like
he one of the ones too like
i used to like i like pee wee long way
too but i just you know what if you know
evie long way's the other one yeah with
them type of people like if you know you
know like
you could tell they still for sure yeah
they still moving and grooving but at
the end of the day like [ __ ]
i guarantee they they situated like they
ain't
ain't impressed by it ain't hurt besides
pee-wee and scooter who's the artist
that you came up listening to while you
was
moving around that you were like man i
know that what they're saying is real
because
they that's that like you said is that
if you know you know [ __ ] is anybody
else like that
um like dolby pw
r.i.p man yeah don't be with five like
that one of my
favorites it was crazy lost too soon man
yeah he was so young like
like well he had alabama on his back
you know what i'm coming from that
country town i know how i feel like just
having to beat them eyes and his his
content around like what he was rapping
about like
you would think he was like 30 years old
when he died when he was like 22. so
like young kid man
yeah so he had a crazy vocabulary